es gab während Corona fast kein
Wissenschaftsdiskurs mehr Menschen
hochrangige Wissenschaftler die gegen
die corona-maßnahmen sich gestellt im
Great Barrington declation von 16.000
Wissenschaftlern unterschrieben wurde
vollkommen ignoriert und diffamiert und
andere Menschen zweitklassige
Wissenschaftler gemessen ein Trade
barington wie unsere Regierungsberater
die dann in den auf den Thron gehoben
wurden mit ihrer permanenten einfach
Meinung gegen wirklich substanzielle
Wissenschaftler also sowohl im
Wissenschaftsbereich ist hier eine
Intoleranz gewesen wie ich sie davor
noch nie erlebt habe seit März 2020 in
einem Ausmaß eingesetzt in unserem Land
im Wissenschaftsbereich aber auch im
persönlichen Diskurs im mediendiskurs
also das ist für mich vollkommen neu da
bin ich entsetzt